تعد جراحه تكميم المعده واحده من العمليات
الجراحيه الدقيقه التي تهدف الى فقدان
الوزن الذين يعانون من السنه المفرطه
تعتمد على قسم نسبه كبيره من المعده تصلي
حوالي 80% من حجمها الكلي لها تقنيه
مختلفه اذ يمكن استخدام التدميس او اضافه
حلقه سيليكون حول مدخل الطعام لضمان عدم
عوده تمدد المعده مره اخرى عمليه شائعه
جدا تشير ارقام الا انها 380,000 شخص
سنويا يجرونها حول العالم
وكاي عمليه لها مخاطر ومضاعفات النزيف او
العدوى واحيانا ردود فعل على التخدير اما
بعد العمليه قد يحدث قد تراكم الطعام في
المريء ما يصعب الحصول على العناصر
الغذائيه الكافيه نتيجه لاكل كميات اقل
بكثير كما ان فقدان الوزن السريع يمكن ان
يجعل المراره معرضه للحصوات